carnot benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire bonsoir
arnaud benedetti merci d'être avec nous
on va évidemment parler de cette
allocution d'edouard philippe mais avant
tout ce vote 368 voix contre sens des
députés qui ont malgré tout voté mais
beaucoup ont trouvé que c'était un peu
rapide
c'est elle c'est pas une surprise la
majorité est elle à l'assemblée
nationale qu'on pouvait imaginer que le
premier ministe obtiendrait quitus sur
la présentation de sa stratégie de
déconfinement l'enjeu est d'ailleurs été
finalement d'obtenir une majorité
peut-être plus large et faire en sorte
que ce plan dont emmanuel macron on veut
qu'il soit l'ensemble de la nation soit
approuvé par l'ensemble des forces
politiques y compris des forces
d'opposition tant de droite que de
gauche qui ne l'ont pas approuvé
certaines ont voté contre d'autres se
sont abstenus vrai sens plus peut-être
d'ailleurs sur une ride pour une
question de forme que sur une question
de fond la forme et tant qu'on n'aura
pas laissé le temps manifeste pour
pouvoir ne serait ce qu'un discuté au
sein de leur groupe et dattiers
d'adopter une position commune alors une
heure des locutions la part du premier
ministre je m'adresse aux communicants
vous êtes est-ce que sur la forme on
abordera un peu le font tout à l'heure
mais vous l'avez trouvé plutôt
convaincant edouard philippe
sur la forme c'était une allocution qui
était studieuse qui était structuré qui
se voulait pragmatique de ce poids de
lutte
edouard philippe est resté dans les
pures communicants qui est la sienne
depuis le début de cette crise c'est à
dire un premier ministre qui ne fait pas
d'effets de manche mais qui se veut
didactique au plus près du terrain et
qui essayent de déployer à le discours
qu'ils soient un discours authentique et
de vérité autant que faire se peut dans
une situation où on a vu que la vérité
était très souvent malmené parfois par
les annonceurs gouvernementale alors
justement cette vérité mal
et souvent un nom revient la question
des masques notamment edouard philippe
qui a fait une forme de mea culpa mais
enfin sur le bout des lèvres parce qu'il
a surtout voilà rejeter un petit peu la
faute sur les scientifiques y ont donné
des avis diverses des masses qui selon
lui seront totalement prête pour les
français le 11 mai et là il ya forcément
une suspicion en tout cas de la part de
ses détracteurs
alors il la question demeure sur
finalement le stock de masques dont nous
disposions je parle des fameux masque
grand public pour l'ensemble de la
population française
pour le moment on n'en les causes à lens
on voit que on essaye d'augmenter le
rythme de production et le rythme
d'importation des masques mais pour
l'instant les interrogations restent
ouvertes à ce niveau là d'autant plus
qu' on rend obligatoire le port du
masque dans les collèges dans les
transports comme dans les transports en
commun et qu'on le conseil dans les
entreprises donc ça signifie quand même
que il reste encore une incertitude sur
la question de la disponibilité des
stocks de masques pour tous les français
la vérité c'est que aujourd'hui on a eu
on attendait un discours de la méthode
du thé confinement on a eu plus tôt au
regard de la situation bien évidemment
qui reste encore très incertaine
des fragments de discours de la méthode
avec eux en effet parfois un cadre
général qui était brossé par le premier
ministre notamment concernant la
stratégie de différenciation
territoriale du thé confinement mais
également concernant la question des la
question des tests des gens qui seront
testés positifs des options qui leur
seront laissés soin de rester à domicile
soit de se confiner dans un hôtel on a
eu quelques éléments de
bien que concrètes comme celle ci mais
quand même il reste encore de nombreuses
questions et parfois même parfois
surprenantes de contradictions et je
pense que parmi les contradictions
majeures et qui risque encore
vraisemblement peut-être de faire
pratiquer en tout cas nous faire
controverse et la question du retour des
enfants dans les écoles
effectivement j'avais aussi beaucoup de
confusion sur ce point et est un petit
peu de rétropédalage il faut bien le
dire
emmanuel macron avait dit un retour
progressif à l'école partir du 11 mai
puis là on voit que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué notamment pour les lycéens et
les collégiens qui devront porter des
masques et puis surtout la base du
volontariat
ça veut dire quoi que d'une certaine
manière le gouvernement à céder à une
forme de pression notamment de la part
des syndicats de professeurs je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez le retour
de deux des enfants l'école pose
problème
en effet dans l'encadrement pédagogique
on a vu un certain nombre de syndicats
d'enseignants au bord de directeur
d'établissement considéré que c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement difficile à
mettre en place et que les conditions
sanitaires n'étaient pas forcément
réunies pour que ce retour se fasse dans
des conditions optimales et clients
aussi une défiance de l'opinion publique
un récent sondage la semaine dernière je
prends jeudi dernier au vendredi dernier
a montré que deux tiers des parents ne
souhaitait pas forcément renvoyer les
enfants dans les écoles
le problème c'est que le retour des
enfants dans les écoles se fait pressant
pour un motif qui n'est pas clairement
explicitées par l'exécutif on sait quand
même que ce sont des paramètres
économiques qui aujourd'hui commandes ce
retour des enfants dans les écoles et
peut-être que là il a manqué d'une forme
de vérité dans l' annonce depuis le
début en tout cas de ceux de cette
éventualité du du retour des enfants
dans les établissements scolaires et
principalement dans les écoles primaires
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire